An American hero is on that train.
Her name? Kate Warne.
She was the first woman detective in the US,...
...and on that very train she saved Abraham Lincoln's life.
When Kate Warne applied for a position in the Pinkerton Detective Agency,...
...the detectives tried to turn her away.
They didn't think a woman could do the job.
Kate argued the women can be very good at uncovering secrets.
She won the men over and became America's first female detective.
She proved to be a gifted investigator, working many cases and going undercover...
...in the years leading up to the Civil War.
In disguise as a rich southern socialite,...
...Kate uncovered a plot to assassinate newly-elected Abraham Lincoln.
The killers planned to intercept him along the train route on his way to take office.
Kate and her agency worked with the president-elect to carry out a daring plan.
After a dinner in Philadelphia,...
...Lincoln threw on a disguise and snuck to the train depot in secret.
He met up with Kate, who posed as his sister.
She had bribed the conductor to reserve the back of the train car to hide...
...her and the undercover president-elect.
The plan was a success.
Kate stood guard over Lincoln while he slept.
Neither his assassins nor the other passengers knew he was on the train.
Legend has it, her watchful eye during that sleepless night...
...is the inspiration for the term "private eye".
American history could have forever been changed,...
...if not for the first female detective, Kate Warne.